hello I'm gonna stop a good guy
remembered so you don't have to hey did
you hear what's coming out this year
Jurassic Park
again Fantastic Four again Balter guys
again
Cinderella again Star Wars again and
movie Giants Iron Man Hulk Captain
America and Thor all in the same movie a
goddamn gun now big shock
I'm kind of a lover of nostalgia but I
think it's very clear we've gotten a
little too comfortable with nothing
original coming out anymore I mean don't
get me wrong
for years Hollywood has given us sequels
remakes and adaptations of anything
popular but there's also a mix of new
material as well new stories and new
characters we can add to our mental
library and feel of the classics but now
from comic books to existing movies to
even friggin toy brands everything is
based on something we've already seen
before yes I know the theory that
there's only 7 stories and we're just
doing variations of the same seven but
exact same names characters and
situations don't offer much for people
who claim they crave variety so why are
we so tolerant and accepting of this
well in some respects many aren't
after all aren't you used to hearing
that groan from the audience when
something they love is getting remade
you know that groan you hear whatever
they show the trims the one that starts
with the remaking Nightmare on Elm
Street
ah they're doing a film version of
bewitched ah they're what ah
it's more than likely you've gotten in a
group conversation claiming Hollywood is
out of ideas and most of the people in
the conversation agreed with you but
that still doesn't stop you from going
to see them does it you're still gonna
see Hunger Games you're still gonna see
guardians of the galaxy a lot of the
centers around the old saying that
there's no such thing as bad press now
true bad press has destroyed many people
as well as projects but those who know
how to be smart and use it to their
advantage are still reaping the benefits
from it let's say you have two movies
one is a totally original idea about a
pissed-off woman who has to deal with
the end of the entire frigging world it
has great actors you recognize and it's
been praised by dozens of critics all
around then you have a movie like first
it doesn't matter how well I made this
one sound you immediately have a
connection with this one you grew up
with that and/or are familiar with it
and hearing that there's now a movie
version about them will get some sort of
response now it could be that movie
looks awful I can't believe they made a
film at Edition and chances are it'll be
exactly as bad as you'll think it
however you're not going to forget about
it and that's exactly what the studio
wants with something new it's a bit of a
crapshoot
maybe it piques your interest maybe it
has stars you might like but something
like Smurfs it's already proven to be a
success in the past it made money and
you remember it so the chances of it
making a connection to you is increased
the biggest crime a movie can commit to
a studio is being forgotten whether for
being famously popular or infamously
popular they just want you to keep
coming back to the product because of
this there's a bigger risk with original
ideas you may look at it one second and
forget it the next which means a studio
has to try harder to make it memorable
and sell it with something that was
popular before the audience is already
there an audience that will react to the
film and remember that reaction which is
a huge advantage in marketing and
selling your product so you can kind of
see why there's so many of these around
now that doesn't mean there aren't
original ideas that can do well and take
the world by storm but why would a
studio take a risk that nobody would see
an original idea when you're guaranteed
somebody will see one based on
thing else and hey if you didn't grow up
with it it'll be a new idea to you hell
I doubt all kids knew what Smurfs
originally were when the movie came out
so they're seeing a brand new idea on
the screen that what a shock has years
of shows and other movies they may want
to follow which will get the owners of
that property even more money
financially this just makes more sense
but the good news is that because these
are projects that a lot of filmmakers
grew up with they're also more likely to
put more love into it yeah we get our
it out now cause that aren't even
trying but this year people were upset
that the lego movie wasn't nominated for
an Oscar really think about that people
were angry that the lego movie was not
nominated for Best Animated picture
before seeing or knowing anything about
the film would you ever think a sentence
like this will be uttered the lego movie
best animated picture well that's
because the creators did their damnedest
to create the best movie they could
think about how easily this could have
been a cheap marketing ploy just to sell
more toys and attach any story
they wanted to again the audience is
there so they didn't have to try that
hard in order to make a profit but too
clever writing imaginative ideas and
great directing we got a film that
people we're shocked
didn't win an Academy Award and this is
mostly because the makers of the film
absolutely loved Legos they did have a
connection with it they did remember the
feeling it gave them when they were
younger and thankfully they were
talented enough to convey that
connection to the audiences they showed
it - same thing can be said for the slew
of great Marvel movies coming out so
many people grew up with these
characters and chances are the
filmmakers were just as big of fans as
well because of this they put even more
time and effort into making their
product as good as possible because if
they fail they're not just laying
themselves down there reading Captain
America down there letting their
childhood heroes down and yours as well
when somebody has that love and
connection to a work of fiction chances
are they're going to bring a lot more
passion to that product than something
that can either sink or float
adaptations of childhood nostalgia have
gone from being half-assed Rarity's to
the record shattering norm
so when a bizarre way the question is
why the hell should we put up anything
original there's no guarantee it's a big
risk and there's nothing from the past
that we can connect it well those are
the exact reasons why we should because
there's no guarantee it's a big risk and
there's nothing from the past we can
connect it's all entirely new ideals
like Batman and plan of the apes had to
originally be created
not retold so even though there are a
lot of good reboots sequels and
adaptations coming out original ideas
are still just as important as they ever
were does that mean we'll always be
caught in this endless loop of rapey
creativity unlikely first of all there
are original ideas coming out they just
don't get as much attention these are
art house films and independent films
and hell even some of them are
surprisingly catching on second if
there's anything our society has shown
us is that we get bored very easily and
when we get tired of something we stop
watching and when we stop watching it
Hollywood has to think of other ideas
and trust me that will happen
remember when TV used to set for a while
I mean like really really suck the
reality show craze was everywhere and
soon more and more people were giving up
their cable but now thanks to other
avenues like HBO and Netflix streaming
TV shows discovered that they have to
try harder in order to keep up and by
god there's a shitload of good shows now
suddenly most people went from getting
rid of their cable to suddenly realizing
that they have like a dozen shows they
simply can't miss we will get tired of
seeing adaptation after adaptation but
again we should probably be grateful the
adaptations were as good as they are
four years Greek mythology retold over
and over the countless tales of Hercules
Apollo and so forth yes while their
stories are still being told today they
obviously don't think up the majority of
what we see new ideas came in and broke
the mold the same thing is more than
likely to happen here it will die down
after a while allowing only the true
great timeless ideas to live on in the
future so if you like adaptations enjoy
the while they last there's a lot of
good ones out
and if you're looking for something more
original check out some of the films
that aren't getting as much attention or
take comfort in the fact that this is
all a phase they'll eventually run its
course one of the great things about the
technological boom is that it has opened
up communication beyond what we could
ever have expected and because of that
more and more voices can share even more
varieties of stories
what are classics from the past and new
ideas from the future good entertainment
will always find a way to give us a new
spin
I'm the Nostalgia to remember so you
you
more we need even more contestants for a
game show filming is going great and
we've already shot a couple and we need
even more people so if you think you can
take me on as the nostalgia critic and
establish your knowledge and have a lot
of great last meet Brett Jones all sorts
of good people uh go ahead and send an
email here
go ahead saying who you are and yeah
just go ahead and send it and hopefully
we can meet up and you can challenge me
to the ultimate experience of
challenging me so hopefully I'll see you
guys there
take care